man man man Oh Candace ignore all the
mess back hair my place is a wreck man
when folks show up waiting for people
actually show up here hopefully
hopefully people show up there we go we
got people showing up we got folks
showing up I wonder what this looks like
on YouTube
wonder what this looks like on YouTube
normally I'll do this on periscope but I
figured what the hey I'd go ahead and
give it a shot on on YouTube um man dude
yeah the thor ragnarok teasers out like
dude like do the thor ragnarok teasers
out then like tears of heights I'm
excited I'm super I'm super excited like
on I am a man yeah I know like it's dude
it's it's it's nuts it's absolutely nuts
um okay
let us let's let's let's calm down let's
calm down I'm looking to see what this
looks like on YouTube do we really have
a thousand people in here do we really
have a thousand no way we have a
thousand people in here do research we
have 1100 people in here holy cow I want
to see some mics man I want to see some
likes see some thumbs up on this video
this live stream um okay okay okay so so
we got we got explain it right we have
to explain what's happened to do the
chat is going am oh my god the chats
going a hand this is absolutely nuts um
Jesus if that bad Chad's going insane
okay okay so so this is basically Planet
Hulk that's really what's going on here
it's basically Planet Hulk so I have the
video down and or I'll have the video on
here on my channel I'll tweet it out or
something like that but it's basically
Planet Hulk
I'm so excited I mean I'm so hyped right
now okay so so here's the deal so here's
the deal all right
a few things I want to run over the
chick with like the crazy-looking hat
that has like all the spikes stuff like
they're coming out that's hella that's
the Queen of hell
all right and in Asgardian mythos and
I'm kind of running this off to top my
head so I might be wrong here but in
Asgardian mythos um the people who died
um they go to yeah I know hell the hype
is real the - my limit notation now
betrays me I'm gonna trace on now Jason
um the whole idea of like the Asgardian
mythos is there are people who go like
when people die they go to one or two
places and I think it's only as
Guardians I'm not sure off top my head
but the normal pert like the normal adds
Guardian that never lived what lived
like a crazy life or anything like that
I just lived in then for a while and
then had some kids and then died they go
- I'm pretty sure they go to hell I
think that's where they go is just like
the afterlife and then people like Thor
would go to Valhalla I believe I believe
that's the case I think that's the case
oh my brain is everywhere right now I
literally just finished it and I was
like oh my god I guess it's the coolest
thing ever do we have sixteen hundred
people in here man I've got 1,600 people
in here oh do the chat is going
absolutely nuts it's almost impossible
like it's almost impossible to keep up
with this thing um but there's also Loki
now okay
the reason why Lucky's in there is
twofold all right and did I need to do
damn I really feel like I should I can't
crank it out now what time is it what
times it's 11 o'clock
no we can't do it now because we're
doing amazing spider-man right now we're
doing amazing spider-man we can't do it
now
will we have we have to wait until the
movie comes about we have to wait until
the movie comes out ok so the reason why
Loki's in that is is twofold
all right so there was um yeah okay do
this it's nuts man like they have the
Incredible Hulk in this and the thor
ragnarok story like in Marvel Comics
like dude there's this awesome moment
where Thor's like Avengers Assemble
because because Loki in the original
thor ragnarok store a story Odin died
when he was killed by Serdar by the
demon entities Surtur that happened uh
before I want to say it was Dan Germans
he wrote it but that happened before
Ragnarok um but Odin was killed by
Serdar
Thor took the place of Odin so he was
like running over like he was really
over Asgard
um and then Loki invades asgaard like
loki has his own hammers made by the
dwarves um and then he leads a Serdar
and like a host of like frost giants and
everything and like they totally conquer
Asgard and defeat Thor and so Thor's
basically cast out of his own city like
a ton of as Guardians die um and then ya
beta right there like beta ray bill
shows up argued mom do not really hoping
mmm I really hope we get beta ray bill
man like beta ray bill was the first
person to pick up Thor's hammer him I
will come and look at all
- well gets that hammer here in a second
song I have a punk I have a broke son
we'll get to that here in a second all
right dude I'm nano so - do you feel you
feel the excitement man you're feeling
excitement like I am I am so excited
right now for this do that that hype man
I um okay so anyway so many why so
anyway anyway right back to it your own
time son dude let me tell you something
if he picks out your arm joint for those
you guys who don't know yarn Bourne is
like this badass looking battle axe
imagine Thor running around with a
battle axe like it's the coolest thing
it's just massive axes are the coolest
things you're ever gonna see
anyway um so Loki leads an invasion on
Asgard all right Asgard gets obliterated
all right as hard it was it's basically
razed to the ground
all right so Thor is like okay we have
to do something to try to take a scarred
so he's like Avengers Assemble and so so
Captain America and Iron Man show up and
then I think Vader evil shows up later
on down the line anyway um so so Thor
Kyle try to remember now um so Thor's
gone
the odinforce manifest is like a kid it
takes four on this journey he ends up
doing this weird crazy thing whatever it
is like assembling these here's what
going through like this whole weird
procedure something like that long story
short he gains the power of Odin and he
becomes rune King Thor man let me tell
you something man you want to talk about
powerful the room King Thor was insane
he was he was like multiversal powerful
it was stupid how powerful he is I think
he absorbed the runes of Asgard like the
essence of Asgard um yeah he basically
goes through self-torture is essentially
what it is um but anyway okay so so
what's your name so she so hella
destroys the hammer for dude okay I have
no idea how they're gonna explain that I
have no idea how they're going to
explain that I've never seen hella
destroy the hammer of Thor the only
person I've seen destroy Thor's hammer
correct me if I'm wrong but the only
person that I've seen destroyed Thor's
hammer was was it the father of Odin was
it Bor like when he came back no it was
more Coulson was his brother um the
father of maybe was Cole um but the
father of Odin
I didn't like he lifted it or he broke
it or something like that and I feel
like that was during a fear itself I'm a
member off the table I had was that it
was that it was a dream for yourself oh
we're off top my head but no the serpent
was uh was uh
it was boar no Cole boar son yeah the
the serpent was yeah that was cold boar
son it was a boar okay cool anyway so
the whole yeah I know I needed to do the
dishes man is my place is a wreck right
now I need to clean it up but um the
hammer of Thor was destroyed so anyway
so what is up happening is Thor goes on
this crazy journey alright he takes back
takes back Asgard and then Loki is
basically defeated and then Thor
essentially dies alright Thor basically
dies and so because of that um four
moves on to the afterlife that was
Marvel's way of getting rid of him
during
war all right so then Thor what is it
Thor is written by J michael Straczynski
and Thor comes back all two men let me
tell you something I this fight between
four and and Iron Man do just do this
the coolest thing ever this turn is like
a full-on here's what happens when Thor
dies here's what happens after Ragnarok
I don't care so um so so Thor Thor comes
back to life all right
Thor ends up going over to he has a
recreating Asgard and he recreated it we
love you rob we love your excitement so
Thor recreates Ragnarok in in Broxton
Oklahoma right by this point Ironman one
civil war captain america is in prison
he may be it may even be dead by this
point um and and like like Iron Man is
director of shield so Iron Man shows up
in Broxton Oklahoma right now is like
hey Thor man like I noticed you build
Asgard and rocks in Oklahoma it's cool
to see you back man
but you got a register man you got a
register you know I'm not just you know
I'm like I'm director shield and I'm not
just some guy man I'm under Ector shield
now yeah do the dishes live I'm director
of shield all right like he's he's
talking trash right like he's taunting
taunting Thor he's like yeah man I'm a
big deal now I don't know if you know
but I'm a big deal I'm serious business
Thor's like no you're not dude Thor
racks Iron Man like he absolutely wrecks
and it's one of the coolest things I
think I've got a rundown video on it but
he wrecks Iron Man and and he was like
he's like make no mistake Tony Stark he
was like I'm a god you're a man in a
metal suit like it's one of the coolest
things that I've ever seen it's really
coolest things anyway that's just a
stage for the return of the Asgardians
thor like loki becoming a chick so on
and so forth now the Planet Hulk aspect
of this movie goes like this robberies
live yet so the Planet Hulk aspect goes
like this such one sauce Rick and Morty
um so in in the planet Hook storyline a
Greg Pak took over the Incredible Hulk
line of comics all right hey Baba was
like we can't have Incredible Hulk
during civil war because you like
whatever side he's on will win so we
need to remove him from the landscape so
the Illuminati Trick Trick Trick not
Thor they tricked the Incredible Hulk
right like they trick hold and they're
like hey man there's like this there's
like the satellite on you know orbiting
around the planet and like people are in
danger man you got to go rescue him Hulk
you got to go rescue those people man
otherwise they're going to die and Thor
is like yeah man I'll do that because
I'm a hero so he goes up into the
satellite all right and then they're
just like sigh and they're like hey man
you're really dangerous so like we're
gonna kick you offer so they kick him
off the earth and they send him there's
supposed to go to like this that's
really like peaceful planet or whatever
it is but he ends up on a planet called
Sekar which is ruled by a guy called the
called the Red King who's just like this
really crappy guy and the Red King came
to power about killing people so on and
so forth anyway um I didn't leave nope
in the corner so anyway um so so the
Incredible Hulk is hit with an obedience
disk now whether or not that happens in
this movie I don't know the grandmasters
there welcome to the Grandmaster here in
a second but the Incredible Hulk is hit
with an obedience disk he has to do what
he's told the only way to get free is to
make it all the way through the
gladiatorial games and when so he forms
his own war ban and that kind of got
summoned I've got 40 videos on the
Incredible Hulk so because I did not
have milk in the back no that's water
and that's paper towels over there it's
not milk um so anyway so the obedience
discus slapped on and he goes all the
way through that whatever so he finally
manages to get away and he forms his own
thing that's a gladiatorial games and
take place and Planet Hulk now with
regards to the Grandmaster being there
he's a guardian of area not a guardian
he's an elder of the universe almost
like guarding the universe I just
recorded the story where Batman becomes
a Green Lantern so I've got guardians on
the universe in my mind but there's a
store there's a he's a grandmaster so so
what this does god I'm really I'm really
hoping he has one of the Infinity stones
but anyway the Grandmaster is a guy who
loves playing games so that's probably
the reason why we see him in like you
know guardians of the you know I'm sorry
uh
my mind is everywhere Thor Ragnarok is
because instead of just having the Red
King all that kind of stuff the you know
the Grandmaster is basically like I'm
organizing games where people are going
to fight and so because of that um it
looks like he's the one that's kind of
running
show now the question is why is the
Incredible Hulk fighting for the Grand
Master I have no idea it could be
freedom it could be that you know the
Incredible Hulk just gets to destroy
stuff which is what he loves to do you
know I have no idea why it is that
that's happening but it is a man it
looks like it's gonna be really really
good
it looks like it's gonna be pretty solid
I am kind of I'm hyped I'm like I have
no idea how he'll I destroyed the hammer
for I have no idea how that happened but
man I'm excited that I'm so excited
right now I guess we can have three
videos no we're gonna have one video
today how many videos we have coming out
today I think we just have one right I
think we just heard that spider-man
video um it is yeah so this is gonna be
our second video for the day it looks
really really cool um the main villain
being hella uh it makes sense I'm glad
they're rolling some exert some of the
Asgardian mythos into it I think that I
think Thor's gonna die in this story I
think he's gonna die in this movie like
I think he's gonna die at the end of
this I mean that's what Ragnarok is
Ragnarok is the end times of Asgard it's
where Asgard is destroyed so I think I
think he's going to die now the last
thing I want to touch on is Heimdall
mathematize i'ma tell you something
right now like I am excited about
Heimdall I absolutely love Heimdall's
character like I have something love
Heimdall's character and I'm so excited
that we get to see Heimdall just like
wreck stuff like I'm so high for that we
get to see him just just fight um
because Heimdall is pretty solid like
he's a pretty solid guy really wanted
like the best fighters they have and
he's extremely powerful but uh man like
I am I'm really excited we get to see
him I'm really excited we get to see him
fight but yeah man I just wanted to like
I just want to offer my thoughts I don't
want to talk about this so much um god
it looks like it's going to be cool and
that that hype do that hype is real man
that excitement is is legit it is
definitely legit anyway guys um this is
how I do my periscopes really so I'll
probably end up like it'll be a little
awkward on one of these but yeah like
anyway man why
man it's exciting yeah Ellis passion aw
smash definitely but I think she's going
to be awesome because we're dealing with
like gods among like the Thor mythos so
how far they are they going to make her
emulation Odin I don't know um but it's
going to be pretty cool I was decided to
see what Thor does with his hammer
destroyed like that's what I'm excited
to see I feel like his hammer being
destroyed will be after the gladiatorial
games I feel like that's what's going to
happen after um just because I'll unless
they reform it unless they remake it I
have no idea but uh yeah I'm I'm really
excited
uh anyway guys I'm gonna bounce off here
I explained who hell it was the
beginning of this so when this is done
you can publish go back and watch it but
anyway guys uh I'm gonna bounce off here
get you guys later please